this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks Neil appreciate the opportunity
to participate in the work seminar today
and we're here to highlight some of the
services that are available through the
library and to make sure you know that
I'm the liaison to this department and
I'm essentially the go-to guy if you're
not sure who to approach within the
library about something but hopefully
some of the things we're going to be
telling you today will get you to think
about the library perhaps at times are
in ways that you haven't in the past and
so we're just going to I'm going to
highlight a few different resources and
projects Kelly passion one of my
colleagues will be talking a bit about
library instruction Keith Jenkins
another colleague will be talking about
geospatial information and services that
we provide and then Sarah right we'll be
talking more about data services that we
have data management services that we
have within the library so I've been
around man library for a little while I
know many of you in fact I know many of
my colleagues in Geneva as well since I
was the librarian at Geneva for about 12
years
well some of you that may be the way you
think about the library and in fact that
view maybe a little bit fuzzy for you
but we still do two books so it's sort
of starting to fade away a little bit
but we do many things in addition to
providing information resources in print
form as well as in electronic forms so
one of the things we do in library is we
have public gallery space and I know
that some of you have actually utilized
that in the past and that's available
for faculty and students to do ruth
presentations or individual
presentations so give you a sense of the
space and some of the different uses so
here on the right you see some of the
individual study rooms that can you can
sign out for a period of time if you
need some quiet space the upper left you
see that we have also some presentation
practice spaces so if you as a student
or anyone for that matter need a space
to practice that presentation we have a
separate room for that kind of thing or
it can be used as a group study room and
in the lower left you can see some of
the collaborative space that we have
created mostly on the second floor
increasingly classes as well as just
individuals need to work together on
projects and you can see there where
several students can cluster around a
single monitor to share work on a
project there's also a wide variety of
seating types or study space types for
anybody to use in the library and this
is in the beset also in the
a collaborative space you can see
comfortable chairs you can see sort of
bar type stools you can see beanbags
there's a wide variety of study spaces
and there you can get a sense of how
they get used we also have this monitor
in the in the lobby space which is
available for you to promote things that
that you have an event perhaps a new
class that you're offering you can use
that contact us and you can get a slide
and it cycles through the sides I'm sure
that many of you have seen that and some
of you have used that another service
that I want to point out is the
copyright information center again I'm
just highlighting a few of the services
and projects that we have and this the
copyright information center is a
collaborative effort with the library
the University Council the campus store
and CIT and you can bring any of your
copyright questions to this either by
contacting using the contact form that's
found on the website or you can you can
email them or just contact me and I can
help you get connected but you may be
wanting to publish a chapter in a book
or perhaps a whole book and you're
wondering about whether or not you can
retain the copyright to that rather than
turning it over to the commercial
publisher and people in this group can
advise you on that and in fact we highly
recommend that you do retain your your
copyright whenever possible there have
been stories on campus of faculty
members who have published an article
and the copyright belong then to the
journal in which it was published and
later wanted to be able to reuse one of
the tape
older graphs that was in that and had to
pay three hundred dollars in order to
reuse his own work because he had given
up his copyright when he published it in
that in that journal we can also do
individual consultation so each of the
librarians here having their own
specialty and we'll be glad to meet
individually with faculty or students
and you can see a list of some of the
ideas some of the areas that will be
glad to meet one-on-one and consult with
you on and this is just a copy of the
web page where you can submit that
request and it'll get passed on to the
appropriate person with expertise in the
area that you need I'd like to mention
just briefly teal some of you may be
familiar with teal it's a project that
was started by man library oh I guess
probably 10 years or so ago tio stands
for the essential electronic
Agricultural library and it's the effort
to make scholarly works particularly in
agriculture but other related subjects
as well available in the developing
world so this is an offline system many
of the research institutions in
developing some of the developing
countries don't have regular and
consistent internet access and so this
is an offline system there is special
arrangements with the publishers total
of eighty more than 80 publishers and
this is something that's been going on
in man library for a while and it's been
received very well and you may have also
noticed a recent press release where we
received a Gates Foundation grant in an
area of 4.9 million dollars to continue
to build this and expand both the
content that's there as well as the
number
sites where it is available is that
distributed on hard drives work yes at
this point is distributed on hard drives
it originally when we started this we
were sending out many CDs but it's now
on on hard drives so at this point 400
institutions scattered around the world
the concentration has been Africa
there's more effort with this new grant
to reach out to South Asia and Southeast
Asia I believe as well and the eligible
would mentions eligible countries the
gross domestic product i believe it is
is what what is measuring whether or not
they're eligible so if it's high enough
that the country is not eligible and
they did they'd be expected to purchase
that from the commercial publishers but
if it's low enough then then it's a
countrywide available and it's still if
there's a fee associated with it but it
substantially reduced from what
commercial subscription crisis would be
so that's an example of some of the
international work that we're doing here
in the library this is a one more
project that I would just like to
mention real briefly this is one that
I'm directly involved in the Bailey
[ __ ] torium has a very large collection
of seeded nursery catalogs on a large
portion of that is actually housed in
man library in the Special Collections
then they go back to I think the
earliest catalog was actually a
broadside from about 1771 and we in
collaboration with three other
institutions did receive a grant
recently which will allow us to digitize
some of our seed in nursery catalogs we
are doing this in conjunction with the
biodiversity heritage library which is a
consortium of about 15 different
libraries mostly in botanical garden
libraries and Natural History Museum
libraries Cornell and Harvard are the
two academic institutions that are
collaborators in this and the goal here
is to make the biodiversity literature
very broadly conceived basically life
sciences literature available for free
open access on the web and this gives
you some sense of the size of it anybody
heard of biodiversity heritage library
before okay a couple of you great so the
collaborators in this case are Missouri
Botanical Garden they're taking the lead
and what we're actually the main point
of the whole project the leading point
is to create crowdsourcing and gaming on
the biodiversity heritage site so that
participants can actually contribute to
the correction of ocre of the text
so these old texts that are in here many
of them are old not all of them there's
varying fonts there's varying languages
with different characters so when the
when the text itself is is ocr'd it's
read by the computer the accuracy level
is not real high and so a game will be
developed that will allow users to
actually correct that text error and to
improve the full tax discovery in the
system so New York Botanical Garden and
Cornell are involved in this mainly to
contribute yet another sort of genre or
format of material to biodiversity
heritage library which is mainly
journals and books and so we're adding
seed catalogs sort of as a different
different type of material that this
gaming will be applied to as well and so
we're coordinating with New York
Botanical Garden on digitizing some from
both of our collections they have a very
significant collection there as well and
that's those are the highlights that I
wanted to provide and now turn it over
to Kelly and unless there's one or two
questions right now we'll take questions
at the end okay Kelly
my name is Kelly I just want talk to you
a little bit about instruction in the
types of instruction that we have it man
it doesn't necessarily have to deal just
with faculty directly teaching classes
we do have some graduate groups
contacting us to maybe set up workshops
that we could demonstrate some of our
services or things that can help them in
their own research so we are your
partner in seeking information and I
kind of styled my slides after like a
paper licka the signs of paper that you
might have your students writing so
here's a little abstract of what happens
when you partner with the libraries when
we set up instruction if you're doing a
session that's in person with us it's
librarian lead instruction you partner
with us to develop different types of
assessment of the student learning and
the whole goal is to improve the types
of informational resources the students
use and can find and it comes from these
questions how you add our thought the
students should be finding a better
quality sources do you ever wish that
your students or even yourself to break
away from google or even Google Scholar
and find better quality sources or even
more sources that are then are available
on Google Barbie ever wanted to help
students
our research paper if these questions
have ever come up to you or maybe
they've just now come up to you you
might want to schedule some instruction
here's a little review of some
literature this is taken from the
Cornell strategic plan and you can see
that information literacy is the sixth
one down and that's specific to the
library students will be able to access
evaluate and use a relevant variety of
relevant information sources but if you
look through several of them there are
several that kind of relate to looking
for information such as communication
skills be able to speak articulately I
know that seems like a stretch but if
they can find the information they can
research and they have more to say about
the subject reasoning self-directed
learning that's a huge one the whole
goal of our library instruction is also
to be partnering with you to make
lifelong learners okay so here are the
materials you will need you'll need the
request form and I
ok so the request form is found on the
man library's website under workshops
and instruction and request instruction
right here and it's just a single farm
for any requests do you want and you
just quickly fill it out and once you
fill it out the big thing you need to
worry about is the preferred date of the
session don't just put fun if you can
help it and you want to schedule this as
early as possible you may think a month
is enough time and it usually is but
puts during our peak season a month is
not enough time and you may not get the
preferred session so the best time to do
it is probably if you're going to do it
for spring December is the best time to
make a request or if you're going to
make the request make in April because
january-february and even in the market
peak times and it's really hard to get
instruction ok and the other materials
you want to have ready and available
will be the assignment for the class
that way when we have a meeting you know
what you want from us so we can actually
give you the information you need
instead of have just a general service
you want your calendar calendar to
schedule your class you want to syllabus
for the course so they can share it with
us so you can make sure providing the
best service as possible and we do ask
and you don't have to we ask that you
allow us
you on blackboard so we can create a
folder and we can flip the classroom as
much as possible so that when the
students come in and meet with us they
can actually have more hands on and we
can answer questions instead of just
talk at them okay so after you make the
request usually what I will do is I will
partner you with your liaison librarian
in your case your liaison librarian is
Marty but he is not always available so
all the librarians at man are actually
able to take your request and provide
the same level of services Marty and in
fact we would actually partner with him
during the meeting so that he could
bring up any other sources that we may
not be aware of and then when you do the
meeting you're going to determine the
outcome of the collaboration and the
assignment so you've given them an
assignment and you want to collaborate
with us we want to make sure we have the
right outcome and you want to determine
the type of instruction and I'm going to
talk about the types of instruction so
library and led the construction would
just have us be in front of the class
and go throughout the different services
that we have available we also offer
libguides
an example who lived guide for a
professor that is new and she's an
animal sciences and she's actually not
teaching a research paper but she was
like oh my goodness when she heard about
this she's like this is the best thing
ever can you create a libguide that's a
repository of stuff related to animal
genetics even though she's not teaching
a research paper she thought it'd be
great to have all these informations
available to the students in one place
and we're it's in progress so we're
continuing to add to it and I'm going to
curate it myself for Mardi makuri at
himself and she has some collaboration
in there where she tells us some leave
things that she finds and adds and they
were continuing to add things ourselves
so even if you're not teaching a
research paper Lib guides are great for
you and we also have these two samples
of tutorials i'm going to show you the
first one this is a series of classes
that
Dover has it been 10 years
around 10 here so this is high-level
takes about 10 years to develop honestly
it does if you look at it the instructor
of the library sessions were supposed to
the professor and it's kind of like a
sequence series of tabs that relate to
assignments that are related to the
agricultural what's it aimed at culture
and can it economics management sup guys
apply economic sorry I'm newer here it's
only six months right so he works with
the professor to develop all these tabs
and there are some library instructions
that are actually graded and someone or
not and it just walk students through
each section of the library research
they need to do that specific type of
paper or assignment for the class so if
you want something like this yes we can
do it but it's give you a lot of
partnership and it's going to take a lot
of time the libguide i showed you before
took us about an hour to get together so
you can see but it's not done yes
which one are you there's to this great
so this one they just go to there's a
URL right here which is guides library
cornell edu / animal genetics so we kind
of kept it simple so they go here and
she had specific browsers she wanted
them to be able to use so i put them in
here and then so tutorials we also are
going to you I don't think I'd have to
come man tutorial in there I have to add
a PubMed tutorial because a lot of
students have home pubmed and how to use
it we're going to add more major
associations and we're not finished it
yeah i found some online i was a teacher
before so i found some online tutorials
and simulations for genetics so the
university of utah has an excellent site
and it's kind of I know it's animal
genetics but it's for basic genetics to
so we kind of added that
did I answer your question kinda is
there a specific questioning what
okay so it's just a repository of stuff
for all the students to use related to
animal genetics so we're going to add
major associations were different like
the dairy cattle and goats and all the
animals that they might study animal
genetics related to a previa and the
agricultural side of it and in this
libguide sorry this one is just there
doing our financial analysis so they're
going to go to the database if they need
and then there are videos that they can
watch that the librarian has made that
walks them through how to do it and the
librarians very much about it in the
class and has a lot of review sex
sessions with them and I tell them how
to track
ratio so it's basically kind of
supplemental to what the instructors
teaching them and then I have one more I
was going to show you real quick and
this is a nutrition tutorial this one I
think is about five years in the making
and you can see it's much simpler
looking so what it actually does is
thanks to tutorials that can be embedded
into blackboard i believe and it's just
okay so basically it's related to a
topic of choosing a nutrition
controversy and leave them through how
do you evaluate sources how do you find
a controversy that you want to look for
where do you find the information it has
blogs it has CQ researcher it's
basically a tutorial that walks them
through and then gives them a quiz at
the end so it's part of the assessment
process
okay so the result after you had the
class we will do a post assessment of
the session because we want to make sure
the students learned what we had set up
in the beginning so we're working on
developing different classroom
assessment tools that would be embedded
in the class so it doesn't seem like
they're being assessed again but they
actually are and then we receive
feedback from you on what worked and
what did not work because the goal is to
kind of keep fine-tuning the class until
it gets better and better and we're more
efficient in what we're doing so the
assignment would be reworked posed on
the assessment every one of us does this
and the more information to give us to
change better so conclusion we're your
partners and approving the information
seeking behaviors of yourself of
students anyone you know we're driven by
desired outcomes and assessments and we
are linked to the academic competencies
as outlined in the strategic plan our
future research because we're growing
and we don't have as many librarians as
needed for the kind of classes we're
getting asked to do we're trying to look
for ways to make more embedded library
instruction and use different
technologies that are online so
expand our services and any other ideas
you might have we're hoping to those
ideas
alright so my name is Keith hello
everyone so I'm the GIS librarian and
everyone who's not using GIS as the
technology doesn't have any idea what
Genesis so I should start with that
basic geographic information systems
which is what I think they put another
word in my title but actually the
geospatial maybe I could equip it what
sorts of things I deal with so GI is it
ma'am library I provide the main support
and also have a colleague who helps
folks out with them with the workshops
data and consultations and I'll walk
through each of these so with the
workshops we offer introductory
workshops and I say introductory because
it's like two hours just the tip of the
iceberg for various GIS software we've
done arcgis for a long time some of you
might be familiar with that it's the one
that tends to be used by the cornell
courses there is a Gianna's course in
preference to science for example and
they all use our joints well a few years
ago these to use manifold and I know
there's a lot of grad students hanging
around you still use manifold so we do
introductory workshop for that and then
if you just as an open source GIS
program all of these do the same thing
by the way more or less but the
interfaces are completely different so
sometimes if you use one itself will go
the other book shelf but QGIS is an open
source program and I'm hoping to offer
our new workshop later this spring date
to be determined but the other two
programs where you have to work
stuff on that workshop schedule that any
money so importantly I love the man
rather than said we have a whole bunch
of Lucia in terms of data man library
has hosted for about 15 years of
repository of geospatial data that's
focused on New York State so we have
data in here across the state things
like agricultural districts the USGS
topo topographic maps elevation data all
sorts of things we have a lot of data
specific to Tompkins County because we
have a pretty close relationship with
the Tompkins County folks city of Ithaca
so we have a lot Richard's datasets for
Tompkins from the rest of the state
Nathaniel we also have some research
oriented data sets that were created
here at Cornell there was a study of
French Creek watersheds in western New
York and just knowing that we have this
repository there was a connection made
with the researchers doing that and
we've now host that data for down so if
you're generating data especially if
it's in New York State I'd be interested
in talking with you to see if it's the
sort of thing that would be useful to
distribute to the public something like
this in the long term we are also
interested in migrating to a new
technology which will also enable us to
move beyond New York State because I
know there's a lot of research that's
being done here at Cornell that's not
focused on New York State so it'd be
nice to provide a home for that as well
this newer portal it's called open
geoportal is originally developed at
Towson University and basically will be
migrating our servers being set up today
I think migrating our date over into
this format soon you'll be able to just
zoom into an area get a list of all the
data sets that apply that you can have
yawn by keywords and then you can even
preview the data this is an example of a
streets streets enter mines for
Somerville Massachusetts and you can
kind of preview that click on things and
get see what data is available for each
street segments so if you imagine
previewing other datasets maybe it's a
tree data set you could click on a tree
and see what data zabila isn't the
species is the diameter of the tree what
other information is available in that
data set so it gives you a good
opportunity to preview the day as if
we're downloading a giant thing and
booting up your Johansson whatever you
I'm also been working on something I
call the Geo load is for people who are
looking for the mother lode of
geospatial data and the idea is
basically a catalog of websites on the
internet anywhere in the world that host
geospatial data so just describing them
basically you know what so this covers
China its historical GIS data and it's
mainly boundaries for example that's the
sort of level of detail so that idea
that you come in here limited to your
particular area of interest or a
particular topic transportation or
forests or whatever it might be to
narrow down to a few websites that you
have to search
that is different wild Google searches
in all sorts of irrelevant things that
you have to give you so on the bulk of
what I do tends to be one-on-one
consultations with students staff
faculty and there are four boxes on this
slide template so these are the top four
things they do troubleshooting software
converting data mapping and geospatial
analysis so troubleshooting software
whenever you try to use our jazz does
anyone use our James have you ever come
up with the errors before ever and a lot
of times you get these weird messages
make any sense what does this mean what
can I do so just uh even if I don't even
know what the tool is supposed to do I
can probably help you figure out how to
get it to go through the process without
coming up with the air this does my help
so there's so many tools in ArcGIS and
the other guys programs I don't know
every single thing in there so you know
there's sometimes a limit to how much
help I can provide but basic
troubleshooting is definitely something
that I've ever try to cover converting
data is a whole nother thing in this
case someone had a excel spreadsheet of
farms I believe that we're all producing
fibers so like mama farms and sheep and
go to all that sort of thing and they
only had the street addresses they
wanted to see where that was
geographically so that involves some
conversion to geocode those addresses to
get latitude and longitude quartet so
that they could do further analysis
we're mapping with that datacenter
another form of converting data trend
rovheir what the original data set was
up there it was basically a database of
trees and the amount of forested area of
different species so first what I have
to isolate all the oak trees and then
the person was interested in aggregating
that by county so to get a total count
of approximate acreage of oak trees in
each County so that then they could pick
out selected counties for like a random
sample or for further research or
interventions mapping is a very
time-consuming process if you ever try
to create a completed map with lots of
labels notice there's no labels on there
that made it a lot easier because as
soon as you have different layers of
data and lots of different labels you
want everything big legible and clear
and it's a static image that you can't
zoom into anymore because it's going
into your published journal paper it can
be very time consuming and I don't do
mapping myself but I can help advise you
on what tools you might need how you
might be able to get the labels to work
out the way you want this was a case
someone was studying coral reefs in the
Caribbean and needed a way to depict the
direction and velocity of ocean currents
in different times of the year so we
worked with manifold
get the symbology to work to get the
arrows at the right angles of the right
great sentences this was another example
someone who was studying frogs
particular species in Central America
they have done all this genetic testing
and they knew the genetic distances
between these and they want to see how
compared with the the Geographic
distances and the thing that was
interesting is that there's this
mountain range so there's no way these
frogs who'd have ever gone over those
mountains so they had to try to look at
the genetic distances and Geographic
distances to figure out which way they
may have migrated historically and this
is just an amount of ethnic regions so
there's just some examples this is one
that actually get involved with helping
with the labeling a lot followed boy is
that time consuming so if you're going
to do a mapping on two sides of a nice
time in terms of analysis the sky's the
limit in terms of what you want to do
and as I mentioned there's these three
different programs that I'm familiar
with and they each have different ways
of doing things and but more or less
they have the same sorts of tools and
sometimes you have an idea in your head
about what you want to analyze and maybe
just crunched there you know get some
data out of the art out of the GIS
program and bring it into your
statistics package that you might be
familiar with so question is well what
function do I need to run so I can help
you identify what tools you might
actually want to do once you use this
was an example of crime in Washington DC
it was the terrifying data set when you
open up images points everywhere there
was just one year of data of arrests but
this was a basic density analysis to see
where the hotspots where I think the
researcher one this was looking at a
rest before and after they made some
policy change about how late the subway
ran and what times the bars had to close
and this is a little more to the Natural
Sciences here this is a geospatial
analysis of the Viper species richness
in the Western Hemisphere so someone was
looking at analyzing where are there
more or were there more species of
vipers in each region and this is just
sort of the heat map of that and then he
was comparing it with
other factors environmental factors try
to understand what would help to lead to
this rich diversity and so to do that
you have to figure out what tools you
need I'm not an expert on all these
tools by any means but I can help you
point you to the correct rose news but
really it's more about troubleshooting
and so if you need any help with any of
that come see me good I'm glad somebody
put my name on something because I
realized i forgot but my name on these
slides that I provided so I'm here to
talk to you about research data
management services at the library and
at Cornell University so as slide for
the set my name is sarah wright and I'm
the life sciences librarian so I'm from
the library but I'm also part of this
research data management service group
which is campus wide and I'll tell you a
little bit
that later on this presentation but
first why all the buzz about data
management why are we talking about data
management funders are increasingly
encouraging researchers to share their
data so this report was put out way back
in two thousand eight at this point and
this was the work of almost two dozen
different federal agencies who got
together and talked about what we needed
to do to harness the power of digital
data for science and society report and
they in this report described data
management plans pretty thoroughly and
the plans that have since the
requirement that has since come out from
the National Science Foundation that you
have to have a data management plan with
every grant proposal really mirrors the
put Alamos report so the NSF already has
that requirement and we're increasingly
seeing in hearing about other other
agencies that are requiring in fact last
January the OSTP put out this mandate
that any any federal agency that spends
over a hundred million in their conduct
of research needs to develop a plan to
support increased public access to the
results of research funded by the
federal government so this is happening
we're going to see this for more and
more agencies this would be the USDA
lots of agents publishers are also
requiring or suggesting data sharing so
nature and science are very high-profile
but a lot of other journals also require
that you submit your data along with
your publication so there are
requirements from publishers so what
funders generally want to see in a data
management plan this is very broad this
isn't necessarily specific to the
National Science Foundation but
generally in a data management plan you
should describe what data you expect to
collect in the course of the project
what data or metadata formats will you
be using will you be using any standards
or data formats that are particularly
good for preservation etc details like
that why are you using those
metadata formats that you're choosing
it's always good to explain why they're
also would like to hear about your plans
for storing and preserving your data and
how are you going to preserve access to
that data after beyond the course of the
grant how long do you plan on keeping
your data you know maybe your data is
only valuable for five years and so
that's okay explain that you're only
going to keep this data set for five
years and it's not important beyond that
alternatively maybe your data is very
important for a very long time a period
of time so you want to explain that and
how you plan on making sure that it's
available for that long period of time
and how do you plan on sharing your data
and disseminating it so this is like
broader impacts so but this is a very
quick presentation so I'm really not
here to tell you about the details of
how to create a data management plan or
plan really I'm here to let you know
that there is support for Cornell
investigators so I mentioned the
research data management service group
that I'm part of we are a virtual
organization and we include people from
the center for an advanced computing the
library Cornell institute for social and
economic research IT at Cornell and
others and basically what we are is
we're just a single point of contact so
if you have a question related to data
management plans you can ask us if you
have a question related to where should
i store my data what's the best solution
short time short term or long term you
can come have a conversation with us
about that if you want us to come and
talk to your department about data
management plan for longer than 10
minutes will also come and talk to you
or your lab maybe your lab is concerned
with how to best foster collaboration
and sharing of data sets with another
lab or something like that and so we are
happy to come and talk to groups about
about issues like that as well
um I don't have cards with me today but
I would like to point out that the URL
for our website is down at the bottom of
each of these slides so its data
research cornell edu and at any point
you want to contact us you can contact
us at our dms g dash health at cornell
or you can get in touch with Marty and
he'll
so if you do contact us these are some
of the consultants anything just sockets
faith these are some of the experts that
will be able to help you with your your
data so we have a wide range with
different kinds of expertise and for the
most part we are all human except for
maybe Wyman miles down there we can't
get a picture so i mentioned really
quickly we have a website with lots of
different data management services info
and we're increasing the map the amount
of training material on the website so i
invite you to go check out our website
as you just saw we have a consultant
pool so we have a ticketing and triage
system so if you send that email 2 r.d
msg help it will go to one of those
human beings and they will respond to
you
be able to sit down and actually have a
conversation with you about your needs
we also do information sessions on NSF
data management plans as well as other
questions you have for example if you're
thinking about depositing data into the
institutional repository ecommons then
we can do an information session on
depositing information into
depositing into the
different information sessions we do
have operating principles we pledge that
we will provide timely and professional
assistance we frequently get questions
the night before the grant is due and we
will do our best to respond to that but
if you give us a little bit more lead
time we can definitely to a better job
of helping you with your data management
plan we do encourage best practices and
data management and we do treat the
information that you give us as
confidential so we might share
information with another consultant so
if you have questions about GIS data in
addition to some other type of data I
might consult with Keith to help answer
the GIS question so we will consult
inside the group but we will treat your
information is confidential
and we refer you to the most appropriate
services at Cornell or elsewhere so the
most appropriate service is not the
Cornell service will refer you out and
that's it for me
questions
you
hi my name's Mike hey Mike I was
wondering it but for our people here if
something to talk a little bit about the
requesting instruction and if they would
use that they wanted a session be Reggie
ler thanks Mike there are certainly
welcome to use that form and we would
always then make the connection with the
right person for leading that
instruction and I should have pointed
out earlier that I'm the liaison the
Horticulture Department and that
includes the people who are based here
if it as well as those who are based in
Geneva but Mike is really the the first
point of contact yet Geneva in almost
all cases it is the easiest just to be
in touch with mike and he can either
handle the question for refer it to me
or somebody else in man library so
there's a lot of collaboration back and
forth mike has been teaching some
sessions in Geneva not just for cornell
students because there aren't a lot of
Cornell students in Geneva but actually
teaching sessions for the analogy and
viticulture program that's part of the
Finger Lakes Community College because
they come to the library there to use
use that material since Geneva has the
bulk of the enology and viticulture
literature within the Cornell library
system so feel free Geneva people to use
that platform for the research
consultation form but also feel free to
contact mike directly one of the things
some of our newer students will graduate
students say okay have you used web of
science to search for resources and a
lot of times they haven't then
through that what I'm wondering if you
offer kind of it
no that's great and that would be an
example where you could refer them to
the library for consultation will be
glad to do that for a graduate student
in particular pools ready to dig into
the literature wanting to know you know
what resources might be most appropriate
for their particular research so we
could go ahead to sit down for an hour
with somebody on that Kelly do we have
any general sessions on research
yep we have had general sort of
introductory courses to doing library
literature research in the past just
open workshops that weren't integrated
into the into a course and over time the
interest in that had diminished him so
but if there's demand for that we could
consider doing that again we do have
some other open workshops that aren't
course specific I don't know that we
have one specifically on that go ahead
Sarah we have 11 pubmed somebody has
come and taken away the fourth floor of
the library or a started is the third
floor going to be available in the years
to come are you looking for space well I
used to enjoy working on the fourth
floor you know I me down on the third
floor but I'm just hoping that over time
well all of the books don't you know go
out for the annex and we end up with
just a big server sitting there in the
middle of it I love all the electronic
access but I also and I think a lot of
people like you know having coming some
space up there too so I hope the third
floor doesn't go away well we hope so
too we've been assured at this point
that that we've given up as much space
as we're going to be giving up in the
library and what he's alluding to is
that we did consolidate the collection
substantially the print collection and a
significant portion of that collection
went to the annex there's still a lot of
print material in the library so the the
library space is primarily the first
second and third floor at this point and
what is going to change perhaps the most
is we're going to be increasing the
amount of collaborative and study space
for students of course anybody could use
it but that's our target audience for
for the library so you saw some of the
different types of space that we have
been providing and we see enormous
amount of use of that and
to expand that some of you may remember
or know that some of the second floor
space is currently being occupied by non
non library staff from human ecology and
from the cals and human ecology business
offices and they will be moving out in
the next little while to other space and
we will be regaining what's on the
second floor non library office right
now and that will be increasing the
amount of space available for study
space and collaborative workspace and
delight I feel strongly and I think it's
fair to say that the library feels
strongly that we're residential
institution and we really need to make
that student experience maximize that
student experience in the library as
well as throughout the campus I think
that many students particularly
undergraduate students are taking
increasingly taking online courses and
if we're going to really compete with
that we need to make that residential
experience substantially better than an
online experience can be and so upon the
part of the library having a diversity
of study and activity spaces research
spaces is very important thank you this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu